[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and where we're going we
don't need tracks we are back with our
Back to the Future breakdown to talk
about the final part of this classic
film Trilogy this is easily one of my
favorite Clint easterwood films and in
it we see as Marty desperately tries to
save Doc now the entire premise of the
movie was set up by Aline in part two in
which doc talked about what his hopes
and dreams were my favorite historical
era the old west time traveling is just
too dangerous
better that I devote myself to studying
the other great history of the
universe women not only does he get to
go back in time but he also gets to meet
the love of his life there's a lot to
uncover unpack and talk about and great
Scott I can't wait to get into it so
come with me my partner in time smash
that thumbs up button and let us get
into back to the fature
three
now unlike the gap between part one and
two part three was all pretty much in
place when it came to production shop
back to back this ladder film didn't
have the issues that the first two did
in terms of recasting people like Eric
stz and crisen Glover everything was
locked in and ready to go but with it
being two movies there was still a lot
to get through both were filmed together
in the course of 11 months with zcas
having to shoot part three while editing
part two nowadays could just do it
online digitally on your laptop but back
then they had to have physical film
reels and also big editing rooms so meus
would film part three finish for the day
fly out to be bank and then work on the
edit he then make the changes go to
sleep and fly back to Cali to shoot part
three going on for about a month this is
something he said wiped him out but he
managed to get the two films released
within a year of each other anyway
that's a short but sweet making of
trivia and that takes us back to the
future and the film begins with the
first showing of the 75th Anniversary
Universal logo Not only was this the
company celebrating the last 75 years of
its work but it also thetically helps us
set the stage for the film we will of
course be going back through the ages to
witness how things all began in the town
of Hill Valley picking up immediately
after part two we begin like the last
two did with a date at the bottom
displaying when this is in it we get the
ending of part one and then watches
Marty goes back to the future this send
segue into part two's final scene and we
get doc Brown's collapse a really cool
thing you can do here though is that you
can actually end part one and then jump
from here immediately to part three
seeing these From duc's perspective you
can just watch these back to back and
then learn about what happened in part
two directly from mty don't do it mate
don't bloody do it you sicko going from
one to three h but it shows how well
crafted these films are in terms of
cohesiveness after the title sequence we
then cut of the sky ju deposing the
bright clouds that opened up part two
this thematically showed a possible
Sunny future whereas in this instant and
it symbolizes the darkness with the way
the film ended returning to Doc Brown's
home we then get some kist eggs that
reference the first film in Doc's garage
at the start we could see four science
figures with this being Isaac Newton
Benjamin Franklin Thomas Edison and
Lassie Albert Einstein cuted Do's home
in 1955 and he also had these images
right above the fireplace these return
in the exact same spot and we then cut
down to see the letter do Road being
dried out on the fire there the
hoverboard the dog cernus and we then C
to the TV playing howdy duty this was a
kid show set in the old west
foreshadowing the trip that mty makes
throughout the movie the theme of the
show was initi in the first screenplay
draft for part one before it was changed
out for that long opening one shot after
realizing Mar's there he then backs into
the bathroom and we can see a clock
hanging up on the wall go back to part
one I was standing on the edge of my
toilet hanging a clock the porcel was
wet I slipped hit my head on the edge of
the sink and when I came to I had a
revelation a vision a picture in my head
a picture of this
this is what makes time travel possible
and this is the same clock that he was
referring to then going into the garage
we can then see a fire extinguisher that
was used in part one to put out the fire
caused by the model this was notably
almost empty explaining how Dock's house
burned down which we learned from that
news report the model cars then shown at
8 minutes and 54 when we see Marty pull
it out the bin we also get the crude
model of Hill Valley before then cutting
to the mind reading machine doc war in
that film this room's a perfect
Recreation of it the model even having
Doc's wristwatch in the clock tower this
is set at 104 which is when the
lightning strike hit it this is given
further reference at 4152 when we can
see the clock face in the background at
the train station this is set at 10:04
which brings things full circle from how
it starts and ends it's all connected
like back with Doc he finishes his
letter and we can see two watches on his
wrists this is something the character
wears throughout the franchise again
showing his big obsession with time now
technically this should start on the
timeline that creates something else in
1985 so far we've had the original one
and then the Lone Pine Mall one from the
end of part one part two had the
alternate 85 before Marty went back and
changed things to the end of part three
that means that this moment didn't alter
the timeline and that it was actually
always meant to happen I think and it's
lots of timey Wy wibbly wobbly stuff but
if you view this in that way it makes
more sense dark ended up ripping Mar's
letter at the end of part one but we saw
that he'd put it back together I think
I'm getting a letter from himself here
yeah maybe what could have changed his
mind but yeah that's probably me
reconning it cuz I doubt they planned it
out that much however that does make it
slightly more enjoyable and he also
leaves himself a note saying remember to
walk him twice a day and that he only
likes canned dog food this is something
that we saw piling up at the start of
part one and I do appreciate they kind
of went back and referenced this now
from this point they go to the cemetery
which is where they dig up the DeLorean
we hear doc say the time I attempted to
reach the center of the Earth and my
favorite author jwes ver these lines are
very important as it lays the seeds for
his jwes obsession clar says she's a fan
of him too and we watch as the pair
start to bond over him when the pair
return in the future we also meet their
kids which we learn to call both Jules
and ver beyond that though this speech
hasle at least egg as Zach talks about
one of his favorite books that is just
like in Journey to the Center of the
Earth which the future do references and
how he buries the car in the novel a
professor and's nephew went to the
center of the
and they were following Clues left by an
adventurer in order to lead them into
the passages he engraved his initials
which were as this is something that Doc
Brown does too as we see his initials
elb carved into the wood after fing the
DeLorean they see the Chip And doc says
now one of the circuit fail says Made in
Japan Japan of course dominated the
economy in the 80s and more even worked
for a Japanese corporation during part
two now from this point they discovered
O's grave and we can see that the death
dat September 7th in the film doc was
actually shot on September 5th meaning
that it took another two days for him to
die from this point on they then study
be for tannan who got a little Cameo
during part two this had him with a
slightly different look as the photo
used here was an early makeup test Gail
wanted Buford to represent Biff's worst
intentions realizing a person who could
do what they wanted looking at films
they based him on Liberty Valance from
the classic Western The Man Who Shot
Liberty
Valence why don't you get yourself a
fresh steak on
me show's over for now 8:00 Monday run
if you ain't here I'll hunt you and
shoot you down like a
duck we then see the history of the
mcfli with Marty then saying and family
your relatives my great-grandfather's
name was William that's him good looking
guy gu's obviously played by Fox
foreshadowing are he also plays Sheamus
as well the one in the book is a man
called William who Mar later meets as a
baby in his crib this is a scene that
calls back to his Uncle Joey who he also
met as a kid during part one duck also
mentions his family name was the Von
Browns which is a reference to the
scientist wer Von Brown this is one of
Germany's leading rocket scientists who
got brought to the US during Operation
Paperclip Marty then looks through some
photos with one of a woman being of a
saloon girl she's called Dolores Miskin
with her possibly being a relation to
Sylvia Miskin in the game we met her and
learned that she was George's mother
tying it all together from this little
photograph to the right of her we can
also see the saloon which is a location
that we go to in the film lastly we see
the photo of Doc Brown who at that point
poses in front of the new clock the time
on it says 8:08 with IMDb trivia stating
this is a reference to 88 mph at this
point M then vows to save him and we see
as he brings up your boy Clint
Eastwood who that's right you haven't
heard of him yet now look what Marty
does at that moment mate and you can see
that he points at the wall going back a
bit we can see that this is him pointing
out posters which offer tarantula and
revenge of the creature both of these
featured a young Clint Eastward who at
the time hadn't made his name yet
Eastward gets a lot of deep Cuts in the
film with Mar using his moves to help
save his life during part two Biff
watched a fist full of dollars which had
him using a makeshift bulletproof Fest
this is something mod does in the film
as well with them using a metal stove
door during their Jewel when do shoots
Marty down from the hanging rope it's
also something Eastwood's character did
in The Good the Bad and the Ugly this is
how he rescued the character Tuco who
was also made to hang from a rope as
well pale rider was shot at the same
place that this was with them even using
some of the buildings for the background
of Hill Valley on top of that we also
have Eastwood Ravine which is what we
see the signs say at the end of the film
this is formly known as Clayton Ravine
because it's where Clara Clayton was
originally going to fall into Eastwood
was asked for permission to use his name
which he gave up to saying that he
really loved the reference now the idea
to hit the wild west actually came from
Fox when they were on set joking about
where things could go fox said that he'
love to hit the old west and have Marty
and dark dressed up as Cowboys there was
the idea that they could go there in the
second film but zus wanted to delayer
until we got to part three they also
realized when crafting the script that
they had gotten everything out of Marty
that they felt that they could get thus
the attention was turned to Doc Brown
with a love story being crafted out the
character of Clara Clayton this was
written with Mary steber and in mind
who'd previously been in the film time
after time this was also centered around
time travel with having elements set in
San Francisco They gave a little n to
this during the script when they say how
far does the 8:00 train go well San
Francisco is the end of the line
although this was written with her in
the par Mary initially turned down the
role however her kids wouldn't let it
drop and eventually they convinced her
to take part in the film Beyond this
meas and Gail also wanted to pay tribute
to the genre which in the '90s had kind
of died out however did get somewhat of
a Revival with dancers with Wolves
winning the best picture the next year
Unforgiven was about to roll into
production and you could argued that
this dropped at the right time so zus he
looked at getting in veteran actors who
would be notable faces that people
recognize from the Western in the saloon
we have the quote unquote oldtimers who
are played by Pat butram Harry KY Jr and
lastly Dub Taylor these were pushed in
the behind the scen stuff to show how
much attention they were paying to the
genre Ronald Reagan was also approached
for the film too with the idea he'd play
the mayor of Hill Valley Reagan's
someone who we we've talked a lot about
in these breakdowns and if you want to
hear about those stories then go back to
our part one video he was then included
in part two with hopes then being that
he'd show up in the flesh for the third
and final film unfortunately he ended up
declining which is a shame due to how
much his notoriety in Western would have
made his Cameo pop either way haven't
got a good segue for this so right now
we we go into the sponsored ad bit
gather around Seekers of quick Tri the
expedited victories Behold a realm where
Simplicity is the harbringer of Triumph
I'm sounding like the games master and
that's because we here to talk about
Monopoly go it's a brand new way to play
and board flipping cleanup is no longer
required experience Classic Fun and
visuals with gameplay fit for your phone
collect properties build houses and
hotels pull chance cards and of course
earn Monopoly money play with your
favorite game tokens such as the race
car top hat Battleship and more and
tokens as you go and watch Monopoly come
to life with brand new characters too I
love mobile games because they allow me
to escape when I've got a free moment
with Monopoly go you can experience the
reimagined world of Monopoly Guided by
everyone's favorite zillionaire Mr
Monopoly they've got new boards themed
after world famous cities Fantastical
lands and imaginative locals Monopoly
girls got the classic fun with modern
gameplay and it allows you to experience
the classic Monopoly with visuals
tailored for your phone I'm D to get
back to it and if you guys want to play
as well and just scan the QR code on
screen right now you can also click my
link in the description and I'll take
you straight to the app or scan the QR
code to download the game now Monopoly
go lets you become a tycoon for the day
forget the risks and Investments so just
have fun and yeah dive into the game
thanks now back with docky says after
all we can't risk sending you back into
a populated area or to a spot that's
geographically unknown you don't want to
crash into some tree that once existed
in the past this is a little n to the
first film as in that mod ended up
crashing into pbody's tree which changed
the Mo's name he also says remember
where you're going there are no rades
you get it you get it mate with being a
call back to this line well we're going
we don't need roads driving at the sign
we we then get what's probably my
favorite time travel transition in the
entire Trilogy heading at the Native
Americans This has then turned into real
life ones being at that spot in the past
after encountering the Cavalry we see
that they have a flag with 31 stars on
it which is what was carried at the time
unfortunately the fewu line's been
damaged though and Mar's then chased out
the cave by a bear now not to be a
mate not to be a dick
but this plot hole it it always did my
head in a bit why well I'll tell you why
you see the fuel leaking it means they
can't get it up to top speed and thus
they have to rely on the train however
however however there's actually two
Deloreans in the past right now the
first of these is the one Mod's driving
but there's also the one that Doc Brown
arrived in this is the one that he
buries underground and they end up
digging up in the future so technically
the pair could go out and get this get
the fuel and then from there travel back
at this point M then comes across the s
his farm and he ends up crashing into a
fence on his shirt we can also see the
Adam symbol which is something that was
first observed during the 1880s knocked
out we then get a see that's sort of
like poetry they rhyme this is Marty
waking up in being nursed by Leah
Thompson which is something that
happened in the prior two films now Leah
or her character being married to
Sheamus I I don't even want to go down
that rabbit hole and how Mrs McFly also
looks like his mother his dad must have
married his cousin look we're not going
to go that way uh and that's the last I
want to say about that anyway Sheamus
busts in carrying some rabbits with a
pair then talking about them over their
supper this again was shot using the
Vista Glide which allowed an actor to
play two characters in the same scene
this is something that was difficult to
pull off and even in Terminator to they
ended up hiring twins to get around the
problem yep Linda Hamilton has a twin
and that's how she's able to do it in
the scene at the end Terminator 2 break
down on the channel right now why now
Mar also ends up spitting out the ball
bearings which came from the gun that
was used to kill the rabbit after a good
night's sleep mody travels into town
which is where we get the classic shot
of him coming across Hill Valley this is
obviously shot in a similar way across
the trilogy with a camera pulling up to
then reveal the town beyond that we also
get a little cool detail which we can
see with Joe Statler horses Statler stud
boto appeared in 1955 and it could be
seen just after Marty travels back to 85
as he walks in further we can see the A
Jones manure wagon which like the mcfli
was kept in the family we not we'll not
go down that rabbit whole L but jump
over to 1955 and the name on the manure
truck says D Jones lass is the Wells
Fargo Building who are a bank that still
operate today however by 55 they had
left the premises with this now becoming
the blue bir Motel I did try looking up
the marshals signed with stinky lowmax
but unfortunately I couldn't find any
trivia however what we get to Saloon
which is in the exact same spot as L
Diner this ended up becoming Cafe 8s and
at this point the bomman says you want
water you better go dunk your head in
horse Trove after doc ends up getting
the wake up juice the first thing he
does is run outside and do this in order
to get some water either way kind of
carries on the trop but Marty ordering
the wrong thing right give me a Pepsi
free you want a Pepsi pal you're going
to pay for it
ah I'll have
uh ice water on top of this we get the
repeating moment in the franchise in
which a Tannon walks it and says hey
McFly hey GRS
let fly now you might also notice that
biif gang is different and this was done
for practical reasons all of these were
highly skilled Horsemen so shoting these
scenes would become a lot easier it's
way easier to teach someone act than it
is to ride a horse and it kind of
reminds me of the the Armageddon DVD
commentary I asked Michael why easier to
train oil drillers to become astronauts
than it was to train astronauts to
become oil drillers and he told me to
shut shut shut the up so that that
was the end of that talk like you know
Ben just shut up okay you know this is a
real plan all right I was like you mean
it's a real plan at Nasa to train oil
drillers he's like just shut your mouth
anyway this time Biff ends up shooting
at his feet and we watches Marty
Moonwalks part two reference him quite
heavily with them appearing in Cafe 80s
and the girls room in the nightmare
timeline of 1985 chased in the street we
then see the hanging which is something
actually nearly killed Fox unfortunately
because of YouTube censorship we can't
show these hanging scenes but I thought
I'd at least just go over what happens
in them the white shots on him but when
filming the close-ups the creative team
decided they had to get right up to him
they did a couple of shots without the
box and the Rope around his neck with
his hands reaching up to hold in between
the Noose unfortunately on the third try
he miscalculated the position and ended
up misplacing his hand this caused him
to block an ottery and in the end it
made him pass out after this fox started
getting a twitching little finger which
he stated wouldn't go away in his
biography lucky man he said he then went
to the doctors believing that this was
caused by the stunt after numerous
doctor visits he was told it could be
linked to that but then the condition
worsened and spread throughout his body
eventually he was sadly diagnosed with
Parkinson's but it was said that the
stunt wasn't Linked In with it it's
really sad and often is the talking
point of this scene so I thought I'd
clear that up cuz I know there's a lots
of different things said about it now
from this point doc ends up saving him
which is when Beford warns him he'll get
a bullet in his back no prices foret
guessing what that is and in Doc's lab
we seees constructed a massive ice
machine the mayor arrives and reminds
him about picking up a teacher which is
of course how he meets claraa now in
what's a great little detail we can see
her before she's properly introduced in
the scene at 4151 if you look closely
just behind Marty you will see claraa
standing with her back turned she's
someone who was supposed to get picked
up from here but with that not happening
she then went into the Ravine this is
even given to us in the line when he's
going over the map talking about what
the original name was this map calls
Clayton Ravine shash Ravine that must be
the old Indian name for it as we know
they ended up saving claraa and in the
end it's Mari who's thought to have gone
over it mentioned it before but that's
why Clayton becomes Eastwood but in
Saving her it doesn't really change the
timeline claraa is someone who can be
taken away by doc because in either
possible outcome she's not present
Beyond this point had she went into the
Ravine or got taken out of time nothing
in the future would have been changed
dark wasn't originally there which is
why she went out and this explains why Z
calls it Clayton Ravine the second
instance was when he picked her up and
then got shot in the back by beer Tenon
the third timeline is the one where M
goes back to help and then helps doc who
also saves claa so that's why doc thinks
it's called Clayton Ravine even though
an a also appeared on his grave I know
people think it's a paradox but it's a
lots of timey wiy wibbly wobbly stuff
and I do I must admit I love the detail
of her just standing at the station it's
kind of fade and even though doc
initially decides to completely avoid
her we see what it leads to in the end
mod describes love First Sight being
like lightning you me the right girl it
just hits it it's like lightning Mar
please don't say that and this is
because doc had to deal with it on the
clock tower and it's also what sent him
back during part two realizing there's
no way to get the car up to ada8 they
then try horse riding making gasoline
and finally settle on the train now
another nitpick people have is that once
buford's taken out there's not really
any reason for them to rush the train
plot I suppose mate but it's it's a
movie in it needs needs a tick and clock
need some excitement at the end rather
than just them sitting around and being
like well T's out the way let's take
time to build a time machine now
thinking fourth dimensionally they
realized they can travel across the
Ravine and land safely in 1985 saving
Clara though Doc's ENT tormented and we
get a classic head of H hard story which
ah Young Love now Doc wants to make up
of the cop being destroyed and he says I
feel somewhat responsible for what
happened this is cuz the man left her at
the station and yeah nearly got that
poor woman killed either way this gets
him more into her life but he's torn
between just letting go of her or
subscribing in the end which he should
always do anyway at this point we get a
crude model of the town I apologize for
the crudity of this model but I I know
dark it's not the scale this is a call
back to this please excuse the crudity
of this model I didn't have time to
build it to scale or to paint it it's
good oh thank you thank you guys may do
with what they had at the time including
Bullock hens on the back of the model
car now according to the wiki for the
movie clar was a reference to Mark
Twain's daughter who was called claraa
Clemens according to the story she was
riding horseback and then the animal got
frightened and dashed towards the cliff
saved by her fiance he managed to catch
up to them and stopped her from going
over the 50ft drop after a visit from
Clayton that man wants to start dating
and from here we head to the Town
Festival starting at the clock we see
his fireworks like the tower which were
purposely put into mirror the lightning
strikes so we've had a Flash and a bang
when it started ticking and this would
also be there when it ended up stopping
D and Marty then end up getting a photo
together which is taken by the movies
Director of Photography the legendary
Dean cundi Marty says
smile while he doesn't now according to
IMDb trivia this is because at the time
people didn't smile in photographs so M
he's he's bloody he's bloody pulling his
leg he's made you look a right knob and
from me we C to the band which are
headed up by zezy top they do their
signature Spin and apparently ended up
playing for the cast in between tchs
according to the behind the scenes Wiki
the zezy top manager apparently triy to
get them to use their famous car for
this film this was turned down cuz they
already had the DeLorean but it did make
an appearance in the band's music video
for the film which is called double back
we can also hear that to buy a cold
Peacemaker costs $122 showing how
inflation or well deflation changed the
prices of the time Marty shows his
skills calling back to part two and this
is riffing off from when he played
Gundam the guy running it also says I
just told you that even a baby could
handle this weapon surely you're not
afraid to try something that a baby
could do with the kids in part two
saying that's like a baby's toy at this
point buford's gang roll into town where
we meet Marshall Strickland hey he's
back and after he gets them to hand over
their weapons he says this to his son
remember that word discipline cut back
to part two and we can see the word
discipline under Strickland's name at
the hour 19 Mark pass down through the
generations the man's been handing out
discipline and we were originally going
to see him die in this film when beit's
arrested this is carried out by his
death Deputy rather than being by
Marshall Strickland himself this is
because Buford was originally arrested
for the mid of Strickland which he'd do
by shooting him in the back they had to
redub the Lin saying that he'd killed
him and they masked this change by
cutting to Dock and Marty you for tanon
you're under arrest for robbing the pan
City stage you got anything to say they
just thought it was too depressing and
hey it's a fun movie mate you don't want
to hear about Marshall's getting
murdered and shot in the back while a
kid watches on anyway at the dce we see
Marty hold up a plate with frisbe on air
that he later uses as a way to stop
beeford this is a call back to what he
did in part two when we saw him throw
the matches holder at the evil Biff
Beyond this we see it's a pie pan Which
is a neat little bit of history for you
guys to learn now you see the Frisbee P
company that was a real thing with them
operating during the late 1800s it was
then discovered these pans were thrown
for fun and hence the Frisbee it was a
fishy invented I said that's 10 you
gutless yellow pie Slinger saving dark
Mod's put into the crosshairs with them
them being called yellow they repeat the
scene from part two with the same
blocking that mody had when 55 Biff
called him a chicken at the dance you
also get a saying wrong hunt you and
shoot you down like a
duck it's dog you shoot him down like a
dog calling back to how Biff kept
messing up the tree thing now why don't
you make like a tree and get out of here
so why don't you make like a tree and
get out of
here it's leave you idiot make like a
tree and leave you sound like a damn
fool when you say it wrong learning from
Sheamus he discovers he had a brother
named Martin who ended up dying because
he refused to walk away it's at this
point that the penny starts to drop and
Marty realizes he has to be more careful
out with brown and claraa she says uhhuh
that one's called cernus with that being
the name of a scientist that the doc
would name his dog after he then starts
alluding to the Future and talks about
how much the world will change in the
next 100 years she wonders if man will
ever step foot on the moon or if they'll
hit the thumbs up button and in the end
he starts quoting ver shooting stars fly
and back at dos we sees a machine set up
to make a cook breakfast this is of
course similar to the first film in
which he had something set up to give
Einstein his food these gadgets and
gizmos took inspiration from Cactus po
who was a crazy inventor and Chitty
Chitty Bang Bang this character ended up
inspiring Doc's look and Marty in the
scene also takes from a famous movie
that his taxi driver with him ripping
off the mirror scene in that as he
practices for tannning later on he of
course also wears similar clothes to
clany swoods man with no name which at
the end his brother even points out
normal hey Marty who you supposed to be
Clint Eastwood spotting the gravestone
we see that duck name's gone in the
photo implying that it could be Mary
instead quit Scott I know this is heavy
now that that's one of my favorite lines
in the franchise as the two characters
have finally swap catchphrases such a
good little line and I also love how
Doc's hat has the bullet hole in it from
where was shot the night before alluding
to what happens to mod in the future
this builds off the back of what doc
touched upon in part two this kind of
speaks to the themes of the film and
when thinking about it it's an opposite
to George you see George in the first
film he was pretty much a d that let
everyone treat him exactly how they
wanted in the end he had to stand up for
himself which is something that Marty
had no problem doing however with Mii it
means stuff goes from 0 to 100 or 0 to
88 and this in the end leads to him
injured in a crash this means that he
can't play guitar properly and becomes
an old man trying to strum away
desperately what George had to become
ready to fight when necessary Ras Mar
has to learn when he needs to walk away
overall they become way more balanced
and thoughtful characters that do what's
right when it's needed but not to their
own detriment Marty then convinces doct
to break things off because he says that
he's a scientist he wants him to use his
brain and not stay in the past and in
some ways it reflects Mar and part two I
caution you about disrupting the
continuum for your own personal benefit
therefore I must do no less this is in
the same way that Mor stole the almanac
and he'd be messing with time to get
what he wants personally though I I
think leaving claraa in the past that's
going to cause more issues mate so might
be time to go out and you know old yell
I don't know maybe we can just take
Clara with us oh yeah yeah take her to
the Future now they then roll the car
off of M he says W that work great this
is actually a little known to the
production crew who were worried that a
DeLorean wouldn't fit the track however
luckily for them they realized when
putting it together that the car
actually had the exact measurements
required to roll on the railway thus no
changes to the car were really needed to
be made and they could just plunk it on
the tracks and then keep on moving job's
done let's finish early this is the way
after getting slapped by Clara for
telling the truth we then see his doc
goes out to drown his Sorrows the
explanation he gives here is also worded
very similar to how Marty tells doc that
he's from the future in the first one
I'm from the
Future I'm From the future
I came here in a time machine that I
invented I came here in a time machine
that you
invented and tomorrow I have to go back
to the year
1985 now I need your help to get back to
the year
1985 guy stands at the bar with one shot
one shot wait is that is that doc from
the thing that's that's bloody doc from
the thing you son of a as he chats
with Doc you can see him holding Bob why
which might make you think what what the
hecking is going on well this figure is
actually John Wayne Gates who worked as
a Salesman for the southern wire company
as electricity and wires became more
common place the man in the company
ended up making a fortune with his
skates would then go on to found the
Texas all company which years later got
renamed to Texico Texico is something
that appeared in the first two films and
I love how they managed to get its
origins in here waking up Marty then
rushes into town and this is how he can
grab Doc and the pair can escape we
catch him still holding on in the one
shot and can tell by the bottle that
he's not drank anything now according to
IMDb trivia this is a not to support
your local gunfighter in which doc
schulz's character ended up drinking way
too much after taking every shot of
whiskey then passed out which is when
the bartender knocked up some wakeup
juice doc Schultz was played by Dub
Taylor who again's in that group of the
three Old-Timers this wake up juice
ingredients includes tobasco sauce with
a label being the version used in the
1880s a genuinely all used to work
whether whether something like this
would work and let me know below if
you've ever had a crazy hangover cure
that's along the lines of this he's Leed
out by bu calling him a chicken and I
love how Marty says it's not 8:00 yet
it's not 8:00 yet it is by my watch and
we can obviously see by the clock in the
same moment that the time the time's
still 5 to May Got 5 minutes now another
issue that's with this jewel is that the
creative team realized Marty couldn't
kill Beed if he did then Biff would
never be born and then we'd have both
dock and Marty wiped out as well so what
they did is that they realized Marty
shouldn't kill him and instead he was
just going to fight him with his brain
and fists th he confronts him and we get
some classic Western iconography such as
the fingers dangling above the gun
dropping his and taking the shot Marty
then reveals the bulletproof vest vests
like this have shown up before and it's
how Doc managed to survive the terrorist
in part one if you listen really really
closely you can also hear the bullet
hitting the metal which was put in by
the sound
designers
this is also the second time he's
tricked at tanm by faking his own death
as he jumped off Biff's Casino during
part two he then beats buett up cracks
the grave and then dumps him in
manure I hate my the kid then gives him
his gun back which the wiki States was
supposed to have some other lines
apparently in the novelization the kid
asks where mody learned to do that and
he then says that he saw it in a movie
the boy's mother then calls out his name
which we learn is David W Griffith this
film making Pioneer was born in 1875 and
he'd gone to make movies which is why
they said it here now from here we then
see as they race to catch the train but
the bad news is claraa has already
gotten off pulling it out we then get
what's a pretty cool Easter egg that I
did mention in our part two video but in
case you didn't see that then here
here's what it is the do Brand's bandana
is actually made from the shirt that we
could see him wearing throughout part
two the shirt had a train in two hemen
chasing after it foreshadowing what was
going to happen in this scene these
Railway scenes are also shot on the
Sierra railroad which was used in the
Western High Noon we can also see that
the locomotive number is 131 but but
mate according to the trivia year these
weren't made available until 1891 I'm
bloody Furious it's the worst movie ever
a here we go again anyway they
start heading to the Ravine with dock
blowing the train whistle and
saying I want to do that all my life so
meus would later referen this in Polar
Express when the train whistle was blown
there
too I've wanted to do that my whole
life Clara tries to climb on board
hits the fan and using the hoverboard
doc manages to save her we then see as
the pear SC away and Mary finally gets
to go home the train but use for this
was actually a model with it then going
over the edge into the Ravine back in
the future or pass for us the car gets
destroyed by a train and that finally
puts an end to the DeLorean according to
nbb trivia the driver of the diesel
train they said to him look you going to
smash you the car it might be dangerous
are you sure you still want to do it he
turned around and said and to quote Doc
Brown I wanted to do that all my life
trains driving into cars can obviously
be very traumatic for the driver if
someone's inside but I I can imagine you
you would want to you'd have that itch
that wanted to be scratched where you
just plow into a car not with people in
but you know what I mean H but it's very
rare that drivers would actually get to
do this so him getting to do this was a
dream come true and I love seeing it
getting smashed like the like button doc
wanting to destroy this some he said in
every film that also being what started
up the whole Western setup that they
established in part two it's
[Music]
destroyed just like you wanted returning
to line of States Marty makes it home
where we catch his truck in the garage
Biff says he's about to put on his
second Co which is a reference of these
lines in the
franchise GRS I told you two coats of
wax on my car not just one uh now Biff I
want to make sure that we get two coats
of wax this time not just one you B FY I
I didn't mean to scare you I I didn't
recognize you in those clothes what the
hell are you doing uh just putting on
the second coat now still ain't bloody
done it and he I should knock you the
out for what you've caused mate did
you realize the storm you've caused
I traveling across to Jennifer we see
it's all fine in Dandy and then it was
absolutely okay leaving her and the
crime ridden 1985 yep just leave a young
attractive woman on the porch when
people are driving by shooting at houses
and just go back in time eight it's
going to be fine a little bit of trivia
this was the only scene shot during part
two that appeared as a new one for this
movie from here they travel out to
hildale and we can see the sign for it
says the address for Success where it's
saying the address for suckers and the
alternate timeline needles ulls up
playing The Power of Love And he
says the
big hey the Big M how's it hanging McFly
how's it hanging
McFly hey needles hey
needles what's the matter chicken unless
you want everyone in division to think
you're
chicken Mar also tried to play The Power
of Love on his guitar back in part two
after being fired because of needles
ruining his life again calling him
chicken we see his Mor ends up reversing
which we get a clue by from how he moves
the gear stick Marty clearly puts it in
reverse and thus he ends up missing the
silver Rolls-Royce the UI fact text then
disappears and we go out onto the train
tracks now I don't get how the train
signal knows the train's coming from the
past but it it does somehow and yeah we
see his dock Returns the Train's rocking
his initials elb which as we said
earlier were left on the word covering
the DeLorean also I love how the doors
open up like the DeLorean and I if you
want a time travel you might as well do
it in style we also see that sun Jules
and ver and I going to point something
out that was brought up on a podcast
years ago I can't remember which one I
think it was kind of funny but since
then I've never not noticed it now as
doc says the feature hasn't been written
yet we can see one of the kids doing a
weird gesture with his hand and then
pointing at his pants apparently right
apparently the kid was was desperate for
a we and what he was doing he was
signaling to his mom behind the camera
that he needed to go don't know why
don't know why they left it in the movie
but hey I hope you never work again I
hope you never work again kid cuz you
ruined the movie you scumbag anyway but
in the call back to the end of part one
we see is a train takes off just like
the DeLorean and then flies directly to
the screen instead of getting a message
teasing more to come we finally get some
text pop up saying the end however
though there's been lot of talk that
they'd never make a sequel I dug deep
and found out there were plans for part
four this would see dark in the family
going to Roswell to witness an alien
crash in 1947 Marty was going to be
absent from most of the script but he
would appear in a cameo roll at some
point however as we know that never came
to be and both galin and mechas have
both said they'll never allow sequels to
be made as long as they're alive at
least which I'm guessing some Hollywood
Executives being like challenge accepted
however we did get an animated series
which ended up running for two seasons
and also had a parody trailer for part
four which starred both Fox and Lloyd
personally I hope we don't get a sequel
or reboot and I think some things are
just best left alone let me know below
what you think and I'd love to hear what
you guys would do if you could go back
in time personally I'd go back to my
part two video and I'd change it so that
I said the Jaws boxes in the windows
were lgn games and not VHS and maybe
maybe if I concentrate I can I can do
that
maybe and here we can see the jws one in
two game Boxes by
ljn we did it we changed the timeline
and now we can rest so what's next well
we will be working on June Blade 2
wickerman and Terminator 3 breakdowns
very soon before shifting over to A
Clockwork Orange I need to stop
promising Terminator 3 but I I will get
to it I promise there's just so many
movies I'm watching that I'm like this
would be a great breakdown this would be
a great breakdown and Terminator 3 I'm
like I don't know if I want to do that
but it is a promise even though I need
to stop promising and either way thank
you for joining me in this journey and
if you want to support the channel and
get to listen and watch these breakdowns
early then please hit the join button
for 99 p and 99 cents a month you'll get
Early Access and it makes a massive
difference to the channel by the way
thank you for sitting with us I've been
Paul you've been the best and this has
been heavy there's that word again heavy
why are things so heavy the future is
there a problem with the Earth's
gravitational Pole